hey guys this is dennis the founder
thank Hera and I'm David Griffin
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of true detective
episode 6 haunted houses yes we're only
two episodes left after this yeah I was
done sadly south yes a miniseries
anthology that's it all right once the
two episodes there's no point there's it
going to be another czi till next year
right but it's gonna be a different cast
to my story different characters
everything like that so this episode a
lot of stuff going on because they're
setting up I guess the last two episodes
I think are going to be kind of like
almost like a co finale that's my guys
we almost get a sounds like a revisiting
like it's been you know it's just two
thousand yeah so mr. like 2002 so like
rust is visiting all the people that we
that he met 95 back of the original case
you know we even get to see Beth comes
in and at the tmobile store you know I
gotta say some you know only Simmons is
a beautiful girl i watch some cheese on
banshee she's one of the leading actors
on banshee that girl I feel bad for all
she doesn't get naked ya head up a woman
she's a beautiful girl but I hope they
may be should get some more to do later
but anyway um good to see that to see
the pastor from the revival tent guy
from the Empire uh yeah the row hey well
I think the actors names like shea
whigham go exactly right yeah I'm gonna
see like everybody seven years later
some people are doing better Beth you
know got a little job at t-mobile doing
okay not hooking anymore yeah well but
you're doing it not for money anymore
home they open up for money and also get
to see you know the pastor who of course
isn't doing well yeah he's a drunk yeah
who we found I was very interestingly
you know found all these like you know
I'm guessing like kind of like child
porn yeah old weird child stuff going on
and can I wanted the church about it and
they covered it they covered it up and
fired him right and said it was cuz he
was embezzling money right all that
stuff so we get to see about we could
see a little bit more about what rust
has been up to these last these last few
years he's got yeah I mean we kind of
knew I mean we talked about it last time
like we didn't really think he's the
killer and I really hope they still
don't go that angle with the rust our
heart being the killer because I just
think it would be a cheesy twist right
and really lame to be honest yeah but
yeah he you know was he's just been
researching this
one case does he felt like they didn't
get it right or they just finish it mmm
cuz obviously ledoux and the other big
guy that was helping out they were part
of this whole thing yeah but I think
there were a small small part yeah but
with rust he he knows there's there's
something bigger this this this big
large man with scars right it's like
this pastor maybe he might know some of
the the guy who's headed sorry to head
up the path with the head of the
organization the business school the
tunnels tunnels yeah the Tuttle's I mean
it's it's interesting because I mean you
know that the one of the guys that they
were interrogating at one point or in
the series said that like there were
like rich matter like powerful men it
wasn't just like some Hillbillies in the
middle of nowhere it was like powerful
men kind of in control of this so you
wonder how how far up this goes the
ladder you know how high it goes with
livers behind all this did the yellow
King and all that stuff and it
definitely has something to do with the
whole tunnel yeah organization and in
either the head of that is is that you
know why the letters oil records yeah
but and then also we you know with the
whole affair thing that's the big part
Maggie soon she came that apartment I'm
like up it's on too little skirt on was
like it's on well she's wrestled room
well Maggie try to try dis late with
this total stranger but couldn't she
basically used rust and that's why he
got so pissed off at the end cuz she
seduces him that apologizes for it
because not because she wants him even
though there has been sexual tension
between the day over I don't know how
many years it's you know been since she
met her in the storyline right but it
was more because she used him to get
back at heart for any she knows that if
he finds I finds out about that that's
it well cracks me up about this scenes
people have been talked about this is
funny is that she walks in there I mean
come on folks I mean he's got antlers
you get he has pictures of dead girls
like murder scenes like horrific things
she's all about getting down I'm like
really I was like I mean this is like
this is over the top but I'm like she
ever girl walked in there and saw that
stuff that girl would be out the door in
a second she would not see on that later
yeah but she's mad McConaughey though
he's a cop's wife so right here she's
used to it she's used to it also at that
time I think she was kind of had laser
focus on this one task because I think
because I think at the end after was
done alright she was kind of looking
around like Oh what is going on yeah
thurs and their girls oh I think she
noticed after work right instead of
before but you know that kind of late so
now we know what the big thing that led
to Rusk yeah and hearts Fallout and how
they didn't become partners anymore and
why rust is not even part of the police
force but it was nice to see towards the
end when they when they when he Flags
them would be a rust flags heart down
and they they talk is like you know
won't you buy me a beer and then I like
when Russ looks at his I think he's
driving a Cadillac or something like
that he's like actually maybe you should
buy me a beer son you know is it's a
good seem like they don't it's funny
because after we found out that he
cheated on his sheet had that affair
yeah which ending is that heart still
kind of sticks up for rust a little bit
doesn't stick up for him but like he
doesn't try to sell him out or nothing
like oh yeah he must be behind the
killings like he still doesn't sell his
partner out you know they're not this
isn't a buddy cop show no this is not a
buddy cop show but he doesn't sell him
out which I thought was kind of
interesting yeah and also with the whole
affair thing I thought that was the
scene when after she finds the picture
Maggie funny picture and then he's
taking a shower and then comes out and
watches TV like just like that's when
you know you're in trouble right is when
a girl not when she's screaming at you
would you so quiet quiet yeah yeah
that's that's when you're in big trouble
I mean I shouldn't say that's not nice I
mean I'm not there's nothing against the
TV shows I'm not advocating men you
should be honest with your women you
know stay faithful but this is TV shows
let's talk TV shows if you're sleeping
with another girl why would you leave
pictures on your cell phone on the
dresser with your wife living there it's
like come on now it's like come on I
know look as a detective he's leaving
clues all over the place maybe he
psychologically maybe he wants to be
caught you know I don't know but yeah
and even even Maggie in the present day
being interviewed she still she doesn't
want to air her dirty lon
I want to talk about she keeps insisting
that then she had nothing to do with
heart and coal right falling apart and
when asked about you know what happened
to heart you know after that affair
she's like I don't know what happened to
him I don't know what could have caused
it i don't know yeah yeah I don't know
what I know what the bad blood so I
think like we're done with this this
present day interviewing yeah went up to
the angry I think from now on everything
I think should be present day up it
should be a you know heart and coal
trying to finish solving this this
murder which I really were to which i'm
looking for to me I'm really hoping they
just don't do some sort of cheesy twist
right cuz as I mean I do want to know
what happen with the murder but the
show's always in their peers even said
it's about the guy about their story so
I'm not so concerned about how they
finish the murder up but I am I want to
see where their characters end up
because we'll be caught up to present
day now so now there is a certain level
of suspense because they're no longer
being interviewed anymore so we're not
sure if they're safe well both of them
survived we don't know I mean we don't
know how it's going to end up which
isn't in as long as either a heart and
cold doesn't also know haha big reveal I
didn't I was me we stay away from that I
think I'll be okay I think I'll be okay
but you know or if it's a some rant like
it was the police chief the whole time I
was yeah wait two more episodes left
almost done cuz I have to say anyone
who's a fan of i watch The Killing I
like that show but it falls into that
trap of the oh let's do a twist right
you know and it's like oh you just
wasted like all this good stuff that you
did with some cheesy twist at the end
yeah yeah so we'll see you think I needs
coming up coming alright guys so let us
know what you thought you can post your
comments below on the website think Eric
amor our YouTube channel think hero pro
and make sure to subscribe to that I was
gonna talk to us on Twitter chat with us
let us know what with dennis and i we
think what you detective are you like in
the season celery is still in the show
you're falling out of it or you like it
even more we're at think hero i'm at
griffin de and we answer the facebook
page that's facebook.com slash think
hero fans and make sure you like that
page and
share our video and Twitter and other
social networks
you